danielle hey how you doing
how are you
i
am here
representing all things purple
to tell you that you are
our sofia so
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's oprah winfrey surprising danielle
brooks with the news that she's been
cast in the upcoming film adaptation of
the color purple
and you might want to grab some tissues
because the whole thing will have you in
your feels
thank you
thank you so much and i'm going oh
you're making me cry it all went down
when lady o dropped into the orange is
the new black star zoom interview with
abc news unannounced to let her know
that she earned the role of sophia the
same role oprah played in the 1985 film
i did everything to try to figure out a
way to get in this movie and luckily i
was discovered i mean it's such a
hollywood story you know now you stay
right here
i'm so happy to pass whatever baton from
35 almost 40 years ago
to you
and i know you're going to kill it
quick origin story alice walker's book
first published in 1982 was turned into
a film directed by steven spielberg in
1985.
i read this book three years ago the
best book i'd ever read uh one of the
most profound stories i wanted to do it
i prayed to do it it's a blessing it's
divine intervention i call it the novel
was then turned into a broadway musical
that debuted in 2005 with a highly
acclaimed revival in 2015. and danielle
seems like a natural choice for the role
considering she nabbed a tony nom after
playing sofia on broadway in 2016. i'm
playing sofia she is the rock the
backbone the strength oprah originated
this character this role and
has brought so much life into this woman
and
that will never be forgotten and uh now
i get to do it myself i did not get to
thank you enough the first time
oh thank you i'm so glad i get to tell
you face to face thank you for
the journey that you allow me to have
the first time i'm gonna make you so so
proud of your problems well you already
have
you killed that audition you killed that
you were just
you were sophia and i wanted to be the
one to tell you because you know i have
such love for
her
this character everything she represents
and everything she brought to my life
and what i'm hoping is that she does the
same thing for you and oprah isn't
kidding here she is in 1985 opening up
to e.t about playing sofia on the big
screen a role she says symbolized the
obstacles she had to overcome
oh my life i had to fight
everything that's happened to me up
until this moment has prepared me to
handle what's going on right now so
having been born on a farm in
mississippi uh born from a broken home
all of that has made me what i am to me
she represents the bridges that i've
crossed over on to get to where i am now
i have been wait working
and waiting 31 years to get to this
moment anything that you want to share
with me
i will receive it wholeheartedly so
please you know because i want to make
you proud
well you you've already made me proud
and i'll be there on set when you're
doing your thing
the 68 year old tv icon will produce the
film alongside steven spielberg set for
a 2023 release taraji p henson corey
hawkins and her are also joining the
cast along with fantasia barino who will
reprise the role of celie a role she
first portrayed in her 2007 broadway
debut yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you